RONALD SMITH: We were
talking last time about--
well, we asked questions like,
how do we know there's an
atmosphere?
I wanted to follow that
up a little bit more.
Someone had mentioned
atmospheric pressure as being
something that's really
important for knowing there's
an atmosphere.
And I said, well, we don't
really sense it very well,
because our bodies tend to
equilibrate inside and outside.
When we go up in an elevator,
we're moving into lower
pressure, but we may feel it in
the ears but we don't feel
it most other places
on our bodies.
But then I was thinking, there
are some other ways that we
could sense pressure.
And I had these suction
cups in my office.
They're not sticky in any way,
but when you push them
together and remove the air
that's inside, then you only
have the atmospheric pressure
acting on the outside and
nothing on the inside.
So when you try to
pull them apart--
try that.
Watch out for your
elbows there.
Everybody gets to
try that today.
So you'll see, that's
atmospheric pressure, right?
Again, watch the elbows so you
don't get the guy next to you.
Now, you were walking up to
class today, and you remember
that we got --
one of the pieces of advice
that I gave you for this
course is to develop a habit
of looking up in the sky.
And what did you see
this morning when
you walked to class?
Blue sky.
Now, what if there had
been no atmosphere?
What would you see when
you looked up?
Black, right.
So that blue sky is light that's
been scattered to your
eye by the molecules
in the atmosphere.
So that's a good way to know
there's an atmosphere.
Oh, another one on
the pressure.
When you're having lunch, if
you're drinking from a straw--
I don't know if you do that.
But when you're drinking from a
straw, you may think you're
sucking that fluid
into your mouth.
Actually you're not.
You're dropping the pressure
a little bit, but it's the
atmospheric pressure pushing
down on the top of the fluid
that's actually what's pushing
it up the straw.
So you're not doing much.
The atmosphere is doing
most of that with
its atmospheric pressure.
So we'll continue to think about
these day-to-day ways in
which we will know that
there's an atmosphere.
Are there any questions on these
issues before we begin?
Any of the things we spoke
about last time?
Nothing?
OK.
Well, then, I want to move on
to a subject today which is
related to what we
had last time.
And that is which planets have
atmospheres and why?
And it turns out that the key
physics, the key process that
determines this is whether
molecules at the top of the
atmosphere can escape the
planet's gravitational field.
Now, let me be clear on this.
The molecules in this room are
traveling a very short
distance and then they encounter
another molecule and
they collide, and then
another short
distance and they collide.
So there's no chance that these
molecules in the lower
part of the atmosphere could
ever escape, at least not
immediately, because they're
surrounded by other molecules.
But the molecules at the top of
the atmosphere, if they're
heading upwards--
and some of them are--
they might just leave. They may
just get fed up and decide
to leave the Earth's
atmosphere.
So we have to come up with some
way of understanding that
process, and to find out
when it works and
when it doesn't work.
So to do that, we need to define
something called the
escape velocity.
It's defined as the velocity
needed to escape from the
gravitational field
of a planet.
Now, if this was a course in
physics, we would derive it.
It's not a difficult derivation
as it turns out.
But I'm just going to give
you the formula for it.
V escape is given by the square
root of twice times
little g times big R. Little
g is the surface
gravity of the planet.
For Earth, by the way, I think
you know what that number is.
g is 9.81 meters per
second squared.
It's given in units
of acceleration.
In fact, it's just the rate--
if you drop something, it's
the rate at which it
accelerates towards the
surface of the Earth.
And big R in this formula is
the radius of the planet.
Now, to be consistent--
oh, by the way, for Earth
this is about 6,371.
The Earth is not exactly
spherical so this number is a
little different depending
where you are.
It's about 6,400 kilometers,
the radius of the earth.
So let's work out an
example of this and
then see what it means.
So for Earth, then, V escape--
let's compute it first. It's
going to be the square root of
2 times 9.81 times the
radius of the earth.
We have to work in consistent SI
units, international system
or so-called metric units.
So I need to convert
that to meters.
So that's going to be 6,370 and
then three more zeros to
get it into meters.
And you know how to do
a square root on your
calculator.
That comes out to be 11,180
meters per second.
That's the escape velocity
for planet Earth.
Now, it's going to be different
for other planets,
because they're going to have
different surface gravities
and different radii.
But that's the escape velocity
for planet Earth.
So what does that mean?
If I'm at the top of
the atmosphere,
there is the Earth.
There's the atmosphere.
And if I've got a molecule at
the top that happens to be
heading upwards, if it has
a velocity less than this
number, it's going to go up for
a while and then stop and
then gravity's going to bring
it back into the atmosphere.
If I have a molecule that's
moving faster than that speed,
it's going to leave. It will
never be seen again in the
vicinity of planet Earth.
So this here is when the upward
velocity is greater
than V escape, and this is when
v is less than V escape.
Something interesting
about this formula--
notice that the mass of the
object that we're talking
about does not enter
into that formula.
So this would apply for a
molecule or for a rocket ship.
When they launch a rocket into
orbit or to another planet,
it's exactly that same speed.
But they have to accelerate the
rocket in order to get it
to escape from our planet's
gravitational field.
So this is kind of a universal
number for the planet,
independent of what
the object is.
Any questions on that?
So that's pretty helpful, but
it's only half the story.
Because we have to know
something about what the
molecules will be doing.
So the typical speed
of a molecule--
I'm going to call
it v sub M-O-L--
is given by the square root of
3 R bar T over capital M. Now
this is a formula you might
derive in a chemistry class,
and maybe you've seen this
one before as well.
In this formula, R hat is the
universal gas constant.
T is the temperature
of the gas.
It must be expressed
in kelvins to
work in that formula.
That is in absolute units.
And what else do
we have there?
M is the molecular weight of
the molecule in question.
Now, I think you know how to
go back and forth between
temperature units.
But let me just remind you-- if
you've got a temperature in
degrees Celsius, you
have to add to that
approximately 273.1--
sorry, that's an add.
Temperature in Celsius plus
273.1 will give you the
temperature in kelvins.
Kelvins is on the
absolute scale.
Before we go any further, let
me just give you a little
table of these molecular weights
for some -- for a few
of the gases that we might
be interested in.
I'll make a table here.
For a single hydrogen atom by
itself, it has just one proton
in its nucleus and no neutrons,
so its molecular
weight is 1.
This will be the column
of molecular
weights, going down here.
Hydrogen usually occurs in the
diatomic form, two atoms
fastened together with a bond.
And of course the molecular
weight for that would be 2.
Helium has two protons and two
neutrons in its nucleus, so it
has a molecular weight of 4.
Nitrogen--
and most of the gas in this
room is nitrogen--
appears in the diatomic form,
two nitrogen atoms together.
Each one has a mass of 14, so
the molecular weight of the N2
molecule is 28.
Oxygen, which composes most of
the rest of the gas in this
room, again occurs in
the diatomic form.
Each one is 16, and so that's
going to be 32.
And carbon dioxide, which
you're breathing out--
carbon is 12.
If I add that to two Os, I'm
going to get 48 -- sorry 44
for the molecular weight
of carbon dioxide.
So you've probably seen those
numbers before, but that's
what I'm talking about
when I refer to the
molecular weight here.
Any questions there?
STUDENT: What's the
R expressed as?
Is there a different unit--?
PROFESSOR: The units of it?
The question is about the units
on the universal gas
constant, and I usually
give them this way.
I usually write them as--
the units on that would
be joules per
kilomole per degree Kelvin.
By the way, either at the end
of this period or the
beginning of next, I'm going
to spend about 15 minutes
talking about units.
And so if you're a little bit
rusty on units, stand by.
We're just about to give
a review of the units,
especially in the SI system,
which we'll be
using in this course.
Thanks for that question.
So let's do an example then.
Let's say that the
temperature--
here's my example.
Let's say I've got a gas that's
at a temperature of 15
degrees Celsius.
Well, that's going to
be about 288 Kelvin.
If it has a molecular
weight of 2, that
would be hydrogen gas.
We can put those numbers
into the formula.
It's going to be 3 times--
oh, I didn't give you
the value, did I?
The value for R-hat's about
8,314 plus some other decimal
places after that.
But let me work it
out in this case.
So it's going to be Vmolecular
square root of 3 times 8,314.
Temperature's going to be 288.
We're going to divide by 2.
And for that, I get 1,894
meters per second.
And let's do it immediately for
nitrogen, because that's
the one that's relevant
to this room.
So for a molecular weight of 28,
well, the formula's going
to be almost the same
thing, isn't it?
It's going to be 3 times 8,314
times 288, but in this case
divided by 28 inside
the square root.
And that comes out to be
506 meters per second.
So that's what, typically,
the molecules in
this room are doing.
That's pretty fast. That's
something like
1,000 miles per hour.
Those little molecules are
really moving fast in a
temperature -- in a gas of
the temperature that we
have in this room.
So now we've got the two sides
of this argument started.
It's time to do some
interpretation of it.
I wanted to consider for a
moment what would happen if
Vescape was approximately
equal to Vmolecular.
In other words, if those two
numbers were about the same
value in an atmosphere,
what would happen?
Well, at the top of the
atmosphere, some of the
molecules are moving down and
some of them are moving up.
Now, I have to say, this is a
typical molecular speed but
some of them are moving
slower and some of
them are moving faster.
There's a complete distribution
of speed.
So it's not every molecule that
would be aiming up and
have a speed equal
to or greater
than the escape velocity.
Probably only 1/4 or 1/5 of the
molecules up there would
happen to be aiming up with
a speed that would be fast
enough to leave.
But remember, they would
leave in an instant.
In a fraction of a second,
they would be gone.
In another fraction of a
second, the molecules
remaining would have had more
collisions, and now some of
them would be aiming up with a
speed faster than the escape
velocity, and they would leave.
And this would continue.
So in fact, if this were the
case, if the average molecular
speed was about the same as the
escape velocity, we would
have an explosive loss
of the atmosphere.
It would be gone
within moments.
So when we're asking about
whether a planet can retain an
atmosphere, we have to use
a more restrictive
criteria than this.
Because remember, the Earth has
been around for something
like 6 billion years,
so we have to use a
conservative estimate.
The one that I like to use is to
say, the escape velocity--
if that is greater than about
ten times the molecular speed,
then an atmosphere
can be retained.
It's kind of a rule of thumb to
put that factor of ten in
there, to take into account the
fact that some molecules
are moving faster than the
typical molecular speed.
And we have to retain it not
just for an instant.
We have to retain
it over millions
and millions of years.
So let's take a look at Earth
for a second and see what we
can conclude from that.
If I multiply this by ten, I get
18,940 meters per second,
about 19,000 meters
per second.
That is actually greater
than this.
And so we conclude from that,
that hydrogen could not be
retained on Earth, could not
be retained on Earth.
You follow that logic?
Any questions on that?
Let's do the same thing
for nitrogen.
If I multiply this number
by ten, 506 --
that's about 5,000 meters
per second.
That's only half
of this number.
So we conclude that nitrogen
could be retained.
Well, as it turns out, there's
very little hydrogen in our
atmosphere, and that's
probably why.
Because any hydrogen that was
there in the beginning has
been lost by this process.
Instead, our atmosphere is
dominated by nitrogen, mostly,
but also oxygen that would move
even a little bit slower,
because it has a molecular
weight even greater.
So that could be retained.
There's some carbon dioxide
in our atmosphere.
That could be retained.
So we've already learned
something about the Earth with
this little exercise.
It's probably lost its light
gases like hydrogen and
helium, even if it was there
in the beginning, which I
think it probably was.
But it's been able to retain
the somewhat heavier gases
such as nitrogen, oxygen,
and carbon dioxide.
Questions on that?
Yes?
STUDENT: Is there a way to
determine how fast the Earth
-- or when the Earth would
lose certain gases ?
PROFESSOR: Well, you'd
have to go beyond-- this
is kind of a crude argument.
It doesn't tell you the rate.
To do that, you'd have to know
something about the rate at
which molecules are colliding
and restoring that set of
molecules that are
aiming upwards.
It would depend on that
to a certain extent.
And there are some
other processes
that may play a role.
For example, the solar wind
coming from the sun will
sometimes take the light
molecules and sweep them away.
I've not included that
in this argument.
So there's a few other things
you would have to include to
get a quantitative
estimate of that.
This I would--I have to admit
then-- that's a good question,
and this, I would say, is more
of a qualitative or an
approximate approach
to that question.
It doesn't include all the
physics and it doesn't give us
a quantitative answer of how
rapidly the atmosphere would
be lost. But that's what we can
do with what we have here.
Other questions?
Yes?
STUDENT: Where does
the ten come from?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's a fudge factor.
I admit this.
The question is, this
factor of ten,
where did it come from?
What I've done is try to use a
number that is consistent with
some of these more sophisticated
calculations.
You can find in the literature
people have worked out this
problem in great detail,
because it's of central
importance to the history
of the Earth.
And I, from those complicated
calculations--
I've extracted this as kind
of a rule of thumb.
So I don't know that I would
rely on this, but it gives us
a rough estimate of how
to judge things.
I'm going to show you in a
minute that this argument
makes some sense when you
look at all the planets
together, as well.
And that won't necessarily
confirm that that factor of
ten is right, but at least it'll
give us a sense that the
argument is approximately
correct.
OK.
Now, so what I did, following
this kind of an argument, was
to take all the planets and
moons in the solar system.
And I did an estimate for the
temperature of each one.
And we know something about the
gravitational field and
the radius of each planet.
And so I came up with a ranked
list where it's basically the
ratio of the escape velocity
to the molecular velocity.
So if a planet has a large
escape velocity, and a small
expected molecular speed, I
ranked it high on the list. If
it has a low escape velocity--
like a small planet, not much
gravity, fast-moving
molecules--
I put it low on this.
So this is a ranked list, my
ranked list, of where I would
expect to find atmospheres
in the solar system.
What's going to be first
on the list?
Jupiter's going to
be first. Why?
STUDENT: Because it's
the largest planet.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So Jupiter has the
largest mass.
It's also fairly far out in the
solar system, so the gases
are not particularly hot.
So this is large and that's
pretty small, so indeed
Jupiter is first on the list.
And right behind it comes
Saturn for similar reasons.
Neptune, Uranus.
Then comes our planet, Earth.
Venus.
Pluto--
poor Pluto, no longer
a planet.
Triton, which is a satellite
of Neptune--
or say, a moon of Neptune.
Then comes Mars, then
comes Titan--
T-I-T-A-N--
which is a satellite
of Saturn.
And let me continue the list
a little bit longer.
Ganymede, Io, Callisto, Europa,
Mercury, and our moon.
And then I stop there.
Of course, I could go on and
on, because there's lots of
other smaller moons in
our solar system.
But I wanted to get at least to
Mercury, which is the other
planet, and I wanted to get to
our own moon in order to make
the list interesting for us.
So that's the ranked
list. Now what's--
we know a lot about this,
because we can detect
planetary atmospheres
from a distance.
We can detect it by going there
with an unmanned vehicle.
So we know, pretty much, whether
these objects have
atmospheres now.
And I can draw a line under
there, and actually the line
is right where I broke
the columns.
That's roughly the line.
From observations, we think
that these planets have
atmospheres and these do not.
So our ranking based on that
was pretty successful.
Maybe not quantitatively, but
at least qualitatively, it
gave us an idea of where we
could find atmospheres in the
solar system.
Are there questions on that?
It's a pretty simple argument
and I think pretty powerful,
to give us that kind
of good result.
So let me try to make a
little sketch of the
solar system, then.
Because there's a little
more that has to
be said about this.
Because remember, what I didn't
bring into here was the
molecular weight of the gases.
I used a constant value for
capital M as I did these
calculations.
So if we've got the sun here,
then going out, in order,
you've got Mercury, Venus,
Earth, Mars.
And then, quite a bit larger--
I'll draw these with a little
bit of size to them, but then
quite a bit larger you
have Jupiter, Saturn.
A little smaller, Uranus
and Neptune.
So now let's consider this
molecular weight effect, the
heavy gases versus the
lighter gases.
For mercury, it turns out that
both would be lost. I'm going
to put two arrows here, and I'm
going to label one L and
one H. L for the light gases,
like hydrogen, and H for the
heavy gases like nitrogen,
for example.
Mercury would lose them both,
because it's a pretty small
planet and it's quite hot.
So if there were molecules
there, they'd be moving quite
fast. Venus--
the light gases can leave but
the heavy gases are retained.
So I've drawn that molecule
trajectory coming back into
the planet.
The same for Earth.
The light gases leave, the
heavy gases come back.
The same for Mars.
But for the outer planets, both
the heavy and the light
gases come back.
I'm tempted to put a little
face on that.
So that gives us some idea of
what particular molecules can
be found on individual
planets.
We're going to find only heavier
gases in these three
planets, Venus, Earth,
and Mars.
But we can find heavy gases but
also the light gases, the
hydrogen and the helium, can be
retained for those outer,
more massive planets.
So while we have this up here,
let me talk about a couple
other characteristics of
planets that have some
interest in relation
to atmospheres.
For example, here's a
category of whether
there is a solid surface.
A solid surface, something
you can stand on.
And the answer is yes, yes,
yes, yes, no, no, no, no.
What happens--if you sent a
spaceship to Jupiter and tried
to land on the surface, you
would penetrate down into this
massive atmosphere.
And it would get denser and
denser and denser, and after a
while you'd begin to wonder
whether you were
in a gas or a liquid.
But there wouldn't be any
particular interface.
Eventually, as you came further
down, you're pretty
sure you're no longer
in a gas.
You're almost certainly
in a liquid.
And as you kept going down, it's
going to get a bit--more
and more like a solid,
perhaps.
But never with an interface.
So the point is that
there's no surface.
There's no solid surface on
these outer planets, whereas
the inner ones you can land
on it, walk around.
They may be hostile in terms of
their environment, but at
least there is a
place to stand.
What about the temperature?
Well, extremely hot and
no atmosphere on Mars.
This one is--Venus is extremely
hot as well.
Earth-- well, we live there,
so it's OK I guess.
Mars may be OK but it's
a little cold for us.
It's below the freezing point
of water most of the time.
And for these others, well, I
don't know what to write down.
Because here I'm kind of
assuming that I can stand on
the surface and break out a
thermometer and measure the
temperature.
But if there's no solid
surface, then what
temperature do I use?
So I can't really fill this
in, because it would get
hotter and hotter and hotter
as you go down deeper and
deeper in the planet.
There isn't any particular
reference point from which to
say, Jupiter's a hot planet,
or Jupiter's a cold planet.
The question is really, I would
say, ill-posed because
there's no solid surface.
What about habitability?
I think you can pretty much
guess for yourself, then, that
these wouldn't be habitable
for a number of reasons.
And neither would Mercury
and Venus.
Ours--our planet, Earth,
probably, certainly yes, and
Mars would be, well, it'd
be a question mark.
I mean it's--there's not very
much atmosphere there.
You might be able to build some
kind of enclosure and
live within--inside some kind
of a pressurized enclosure.
But it wouldn't be a very
pleasant existence for us.
So habitability is pretty much
limited to Earth, and maybe
Mars if you want to extend the
definition a little bit.
Questions on that?
Give me just a minute.
I want to show you a
few things here.
So this is the diagram I already
really have on the
blackboard.
It's not to scale either.
I mean these distances
are not to scale.
But you get some idea of the
fact that these inner planets
are a lot smaller than
the outer planets.
For example, we know Jupiter has
an atmosphere because we
can see these cloud patterns
moving around
at very great speeds.
And the Great Red Spot, which I
don't think is shown there,
is a giant vortex like a
hurricane, but 1,000 times the
size, sitting in Jupiter's
atmosphere, winds
swirling around it.
So it's obvious that Jupiter
has an atmosphere.
But so do all of these.
And so does Mars and
Venus and Earth.
It's only Mercury on this
diagram that does not have a
planetary atmosphere.
So it's convenient to break up
the planets into two general
categories.
The so-called terrestrial
planets, which
are a bit like Earth--
they comprise Mercury, Venus,
Earth, and Mars.
They're small, they're dense,
they have rocky surfaces, they
rotate relatively slowly
on their axis.
For Earth, it takes,
as you know,
twenty-four hours to go around.
The atmosphere--
well, none in the case of
Mercury, but the heavier gases
in the case of Earth, Mars,
and Venus, with molecular
weight somewhere in the range of
four to fifty, I would say.
Whereas, the Jovian planets--
that is, the planets that are
like Jupiter in some way--
are much larger, much
lower density.
They have soft surfaces, they
rotate more rapidly than
Earth, and their atmosphere
is primarily
composed of light gases.
Mostly hydrogen with a molecular
weight of two in the
diatomic form, and helium, just
independent helium atoms
with a molecular
weight of four.
So there are the terrestrial
planets.
I'll show you more about this,
but that's Earth, Venus, Mars,
and Mercury.
And the outer planets,
the Jovian planets.
That's the list. I already have
it on the board, so you
don't have to write
that down again.
This is also a review.
I think we've been
through this.
But Mercury has no atmosphere.
Venus has a massive
CO2 atmosphere.
It is entirely covered
by clouds.
100% cloud cover all the
time, which makes it
a very bright planet.
In fact, do you know the
colloquial term for Venus
among astronomers, or
farmers, or sailors?
STUDENT: Do they call it
the greenhouse planet?
PROFESSOR: No, not colloquially.
The evening star.
It's called the evening star.
That's an odd name, isn't it?
Because it's not
a star at all.
But when the sun sets in the
evening and the sky darkens,
that's usually the first
thing you can see.
So the evening star,
they call it.
Why is it?
Because it's--well it's
relatively large, relatively
close, but it's very bright.
It reflects--it's completely
covered with white clouds,
reflects a lot of sunlight,
and makes it
easy for us to see.
It turns out, though,
that it also has a
super greenhouse effect.
And it's a little bit closer
to the sun than we are, but
its temperature is even hotter
than you would expect based on
that proximity to the sun.
It has a really super greenhouse
effect that brings
it up to a temperature that's
in the order of 600 Celsius,
way, way, way above the
boiling point and
so on and so forth.
So a very hot planet because
of the greenhouse effect.
The Earth we know has a
nitrogen-oxygen atmosphere primarily.
Partly cloudy.
Water can exist in
the liquid form.
We have life, and we
have ice caps.
We have frozen water, in this
case in the form of snow or
frozen seawater, at the caps,
at the poles of the planet.
Mars has a CO2 atmosphere
but not much of it.
There may have been
water there once.
We don't know if it's
still there now.
There may have been
life there once.
We don't think it's there now.
But it too has some ice caps.
If you look at the planet, it
has these kind of snowy
regions near the poles.
We don't think it's
frozen water.
We think it's frozen C02.
What's frozen CO2 called?
Dry ice.
Dry ice is what we
call frozen CO2.
Mars seems to have dry ice ice
caps on the poles that change
a bit with the season.
So the point here--
we're not going to be studying,
in the rest of the
course, much more about
these other planets.
But the point of today's lecture
is to put Earth in
some kind of context, especially
in relation to how
our atmosphere is composed,
how it's retained.
Later on, we'll be talking about
the greenhouse effect on
Venus and why that might
be a concern for us.
Questions here?
So there's Mercury.
A rugged surface,
pockmarked with
meteorite collision craters.
Remember, no atmosphere.
There's Venus.
Now, neither of these
pictures of Venus is
taken in visible light.
What you would see with your eye
is a uniform, featureless
white surface.
When you look at it in the
ultraviolet, you begin to see
a little bit of difference
between some of the clouds,
and these would be moving very
rapidly around the planet, if
you had a movie of this.
So you can see-distinguish, a
little bit, low clouds from
high clouds and see that
they're moving.
When you use radar to look at
Venus, you can penetrate
through the clouds in
the atmosphere.
And you see that it has
a rough surface,
indicated like that.
Earth, of course, you're
familiar with.
It's partly cloudy.
Those clouds are composed
of condensed water.
We'll talk a lot about that.
Mars has an atmosphere.
You occasionally, I believe,
see a cloud.
A rare cloud will appear in
the Martian atmosphere.
There's an ice cap up there.
But for the most part you don't
see anything moving
around on Mars.
But we know there's an
atmosphere there.
We have lots of-- we've
been there.
We've had landers there,
I mean, not humans.
We've had landers there, and
from a number of other clues,
we know that there's a thin
CO2 atmosphere on Mars.
Now, you've all had--I suspect
you've all had a chemistry
course and seen the periodic
table of the elements.
I just wanted to show this to
you to remind you a little bit
about that.
What are the molecules we're
going to mostly be concerned
with in this course?
What are the elements that
make up those molecules?
In red, I have circled the
elements that you find most
often in atmospheres.
So, for example, nitrogen in
the diatomic form is the
dominant molecule in the
Earth's atmosphere.
Next after that is oxygen
in the diatomic form.
And there's a little bit
of argon, also, in our
atmosphere.
There's a variable
amount of CO2.
Combine carbon and oxygen
and you can get CO2.
I'll show you a list of some
of these other important
molecules in just a minute.
But it's the red ones, with
their light masses and their
preference for either bonding
not at all with other
molecules, or their preference
for bonding with other light
molecules, that makes them good
candidates for being an
atmospheric gas.
In the black circles are
the dominant elements
in the solid Earth.
Sodium, manganese, potassium,
calcium,
iron, aluminum, silicon.
So all these others are found as
well, but the dominant ones
are the ones I've
found in black.
Now, they--first of all, they
tend to be heavier by
themselves.
And then the way they bond will
make them heavier still.
And therefore you wouldn't
expect to find them as
atmospheric gases.
You'd rather find them in some
more condensed body like the
solid Earth.
STUDENT: Are those found
in the outer planets?
PROFESSOR: The question is whether these
molecules are found in
the outer planets.
They all are, yes-- in various
proportions, though.
The ratio of the abundances of
the elements does change a
little bit from planet to
planet, but not dramatically.
The planets were all formed
more or less from the same
type of material, and so if you
include everything all the
way from the surface--top of the
atmosphere to the center
of the planet, there's a
remarkable similarity between
the compositions of the
different planets.
For example, in the case of
Jupiter, it probably has all
of these elements.
They're probably down in the
interior parts of the planet.
And up near the--in the upper
parts, you only have hydrogen
and helium up in
the atmosphere.
But those are probably
all in there as well.
Any other questions here?
Good.
I think that maybe--
yes.
So here's some of the
important atmospheric molecules.
You should be aware of these
at least. If I gave you the
name, you could give me the
formula and so on, for these.
We've already talked
about diatomic
nitrogen, oxygen, CO2.
Methane is an important
greenhouse gas, CH4, carbon
with four hydrogens.
Ozone is simply adding another
oxygen atom to diatomic.
It's just triatomic oxygen.
Water is H2O, you know that.
Diatomic--
so we've been through
most of these.
I won't spend any more-- some
of these are important air
pollutants in the earth's
atmosphere.
So we'll be coming back to
studying this group, for
example, later on in
the course when we
talk about air pollution.
I'm going to end with that.
Let's see.
We're going to be--in a day or
so, we're going to be talking
about the vertical temperature
structure on Earth.
And since I'm not a very good
artist, I thought I
would show you this.
But this is in your
textbook as well.
This is the temperature in the
Earth's atmosphere as a
function of altitude.
And it starts around fifteen
degrees Celsius, and that's
the example I used today, and
then it cools off, warms up
again with altitude, cools off
again, warms up with altitude.
Think about that profile, and in
a day or two, I'm going to
be asking you to speculate
about why it is that the
Earth's atmosphere has this
peculiar structure.
The other planets, by the
way, have a structure
that's a bit simpler.
It cools and then warms, just
one cooling trend and one
warming trend in the atmospheres
of most of the
other planets.
So there's something unique
about our planet that gives it
this layer cake structure
of temperature.
So let's see.
That takes care of that.
And let me ask again if there
any questions at this point.
Question in front.
Yes?
STUDENT: Are these slides
on--will they be online?
PROFESSOR: They will be.
By the end of the day,
they'll be up there.
Yeah.
OK.
We're--I don't have time to
start the next subject.
So let's call it quits today.
When you see me on Monday, I'm
going to dive into this review
of the SI system of units.
We're going to talk about
the perfect gas law.
warm air and cold
air rising and sinking.
We're going to start into some
of the physics of how our
atmosphere works on Monday.
See you then.